du pétrole en plein paris un forage a
commencé tout à l'heure sous la capitale
précisément à la porte d'ivry une
expérience mais peut-être aussi un
espoir
la mort de félix leclerc c'est la
disparition d'un grand poète francophone
à l'un d'eux cours ministre de la
francophonie sera aussi notre invité
dans cette édition
carnet rose à la cour d'angleterre sarah
la femme d'andrew a mis au monde une
fille elle sera la cinquième dans
l'ordre de succession au trône
britannique
samedi 20 août trois heures gmt les
armes vont se taire pour la première
fois depuis huit ans l'iran et l'irak
ont accepté un cessez le feu il devrait
mettre un terme à huit ans de conflit le
plus meurtrier depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale
et puis le 25 août à genève les deux
belligérants vont entamer des
négociations directes
l'annoncé officielle de ce cessez le feu
a eu lieu la nuit dernière à new york
aux nations unies c'est monsieur perez
de cuellar le secrétaire général qui a
appelé les deux pays à observer la trêve
gilles rabin anarcho la pente en irak
dès l'annoncé du cessez-le-feu par le
secrétaire général de l'onu
l'explosion de joie immédiate et
spontanée dans les rues de bagdad la
capitale irakienne
une liesse populaire dont saddam hussein
a voulu tirer un profit politique
immédiat venu à la grande mosquée
remercier allah du cessez-le-feu et de
la paix qui s'annonce
grâce à ce qu'il considère être une
victoire militaire irakienne
saddam hussein est venu se mêler à la
foule et a octroyé trois jours de fête à
ces rescapés des combats qui à cannes
leur chef en irak pays trois fois moins
peuplé que l'iran toutes les familles
ont été touchées par la guerre
un mari un fils ou un neveu tué ou
blessé
à téhéran le cessez-le-feu a été
accueillie d'une manière beaucoup plus
modérée nous n'avons reçu aucune image
d'iran et nous ne pouvons donc pas à
vous en montrer on sait cependant que
les autorités iraniennes ont demandé à
leurs combattants de respecter dès
maintenant le cessez le feu monsieur
rafsandjani le commandant en chef des
forces armées l'a dit dans un message
solennel en leur demandant toutefois de
rester vigilants et en état d' alerte
réactions dans le monde entier à paris
satisfaction du gouvernement français
c'est ce qui expliquait ce matin un
communiqué du quai d'orsay
même chose ce matin aussi à washington
et cet après midi à moscou tout le monde
rend hommage à monsieur perez de cuellar
le secrétaire général de
nu dans quelques instants nous serons
avec lui en liaison de new york mais
auparavant il faut revenir sur les
raisons qui ont poussé les deux pays a
fait c'est enfin la guerre plus d'un
million de morts en huit ans de guerre
cette fontaine de sens symbolique aura
coulé au delà des limites du supportable
pour l'irak comme pour l'iran cette
fontaine 200 avaient été dressées dans
téhéran au début de la guerre pour
galvaniser l'ardeur des foules iranienne
elle représentait le sens des futurs
martyrs à l'époque khomeiny juré de
combattre jusqu'à la mort de son ennemi
saddam hussein hussein lui voulait la
mort de khomeiny et de sa révolution
aujourd'hui les deux ennemis mortels
d'hier vont devoir se retrouver pour
faire la paix les raisons de leurs
revirements tiennent en un seul mot
épuisement épuisement militaire bien sûr
l'irak et l'iran auront dépensé à eux
deux près d'un milliard de dollars 6
milliards de francs en armement de
toutes sortes pour une guerre qui n'a
fait finalement ni vainqueur ni vaincu
épuisement économique ensuite la guerre
des villes d'une part 30 villes touchées
dans les deux camps par plus de 300
missiles et des centaines de civils tués
ou blessés
la guerre des pétroliers d'autre part
500 navires touchés en quatre ans les
routes iraniennes et irakiennes du
pétrole progressivement asphyxié
ces deux guerres à el sol ont accéléré
la dégradation des économies des deux
pays
pendant l'effort de guerre chaque jour
plus insupportable épuisement
idéologique pour l'iran l'ayatollah
khomeini ne parvenant plus à mobiliser
les énergies révolutionnaire pour la
guerre sainte et la défense sacrée du
territoire national
épuisement politique et diplomatique
pour l'irak
discrédité auprès de ses plus fidèles
alliés par l'emploi massif des armes
chimiques épuisement moral enfin des
deux pays et des deux leaders
saddam hussein et khomeiny qui vont tous
les deux devoir affronter dès l'entrée
en vigueur du cessez le feu
les dissensions intérieures longtemps
étouffée par la guerre voilà pour les
faits invité exceptionnel de ce journal
ce soir le secrétaire général de l'onu
monsieur perez de cuellar qui est à new
york en ce moment monsieur perez de
cuellar
bonsoir merci surtout d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors j'imagine
monsieur perez de cuellar que vous êtes
un homme heureux ce soir oui je suis
assez satisfait parce que nous sommes
arrivés à mettre fin à une guerre qui a
traîné pendant huit ans et bien sûr il
faut comprendre que c'est ce que nous
avons obtenu c'est pas seulement à
cesser le feu mais celle de vue d'une
négociation que nous espérons va nous
mener à la solution finale du conflit
mais vous êtes optimiste ce soir je suis
optimiste oui enfin je n'ai pas vous
poussez mois optimiste qui parfois des
routes le monde mais j'ai des raisons
pour avoir bon espoir que nous allons
réussir
nous allons obtenir une solution finale
globale des problèmes alors la question
qui se pose à propos de ces conflits
c'est pourquoi n'ont ils pu trouver une
solution plutôt pourquoi pas il y a un
an par exemple qu'est-ce qui a changé
depuis un an sur le plan international
évitez les grandes puissances en tant
que membres permanents du conseil
sécurité étaient engagés à la solution
du problème c'est à dire à la mise en
oeuvre de la résolution 598 alors tu
essaies point de vue là ils ont joué un
rôle très important d'autant plus qu'ils
m'ont donné un appui extrêmement ferme
tous les long des mes discussions avec
les deux parties
alors je pensais en particulier l'union
qu'est ce que l'arrivée par exemple de
mikhaïl gorbatchev sur la scène
internationale vous qui êtes secrétaire
général de l'onu depuis de nombreuses
années que vous avez senti un changement
écoutez vous avez le fait que les deux
les deux grandes puissances les
etats-unis l est et l'union soviétique
et ses musées soit mis d'accord sur
certains sujets bien sûr à créer une
atmosphère qui l'évasion à direct a
probablement favorisé les résultats que
nous avons obtenus hier vous avez le
sentiment monsieur découvrir ce soir que
l'action personnelle d'un homme en
l'occurrence la vôtre peut être décisif
dans la paix mondiale écoutez vous avez
vous me posez une question très
difficile à répondre vous avez j'étais
les médiateurs désignés par les conseils
de sécurité j'ai agi suivant les
instructions du conseil sécurité et j'ai
mis en fin et tout mon enthousiasme et
mon expérience de leurs années au
service de la paix merci monsieur perez
de cuellar merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
c'est moi qui vont vers ces autres
conflits si on voit deux solutions
l'angola et c'est encore grâce aux
efforts de l'onu
le cessez-le-feu ce sera mercredi nous
vous le disions dévié hier les trois
pays concernés c'est-à-dire l'afrique du
sud l'angola et cuba sont parvenus à
mettre un terme à leurs divergences là
encore c'est la fin d'un conflit
régional qui durait depuis très
longtemps contre cornu après l'arrêt
effectif des combats depuis hier au sud
de l'angola et au nord de la namibie les
troupes sud africaine estimé à 9000
hommes selon luanda devront avoir quitté
l'angola au plus tard le 1er septembre
date à laquelle les cubains qui
entretiennent pour leur part 50 mille
hommes sur le terrain conseillé par des
soviétiques devront présenter un
calendrier de repli de leurs propres
forces
l'accord conclu le 5 août à genève
débouchent sur le départ des troupes sud
africaine dans les 15 jours et en
préservant cet accord hier à genève les
responsables sud-africains souligné
l'existence d'un lien direct entre
l'accession de la namibie à la
dépendance et le retrait cubain lien
exigé depuis le début des années 80 par
pretoria et washington un accord qui
laisse les rebelles angolais de l'unité
opposés au gouvernement marxiste de
luanda privés de leur aide ceux d'air
frais
kane et qui ont fait savoir qu'ils ne se
sentaient pas tenu de respecter ce
cessez le feu signé entre luanda
pretoria et la havane cessez-le-feu
certes mais certainement pas la fin du
conflit en angola qui a fait en 13 ans
depuis l'indépendance du pays
plus de soixante mille morts cubain
soviétique américains et sud africains
se sont impliqués dans ce conflit
angolais avec le même objectif le
contrôle stratégique et économique de
l'afrique australe l'angola peuplé de
neuf millions d'habitants et pays clés
avec ses richesses minières
en revanche en birmanie tout au bout de
la vie il ya eu aujourd'hui de graves
d'affrontements depuis plusieurs
semaines des manifestations ont lieu
quotidiennement
l'armée a ouvert le feu aujourd'hui dans
la capitale rangoon est aussi dans la
ville de saguenay
il y a des dizaines de morts dans les
deux cas des milliers de manifestants
demandaient le départ du président
salling pour l'instant nous n'en savons
pas plus les communications et la
birmanie sont très difficiles
et puis au chapitre du terrorisme l'aveu
de moi mais l'armada il s'agite ce
libanais jugé affronte fort en ce moment
pour le détournement du boeing de la twh
en juin 85 mbj
surprise donc ce matin hamadé a reconnu
pour la première fois qu'il avait
participé au détournement patrice de
l'est il a signé ses aveux mohamed
hamadeh reconnaît ses actes terroristes
devant ses juges détournement d'un avion
de ligne américain
prise en otage de 39 passagers pendant
19 jours de sa prison de francfort où se
déroule son procès il a déclaré ce
n'était pas un acte de fanatisme
religieux
c'était un acte politique aéroport de
beyrouth juin 85 plusieurs pirates de
l'air menace la vie de leur otage
une revendication la libération de
prisonniers chiites détenus en israël
pour preuve de leur détermination un
otage assassiné mois mais damas day n'a
jamais reconnu cette exécution
il accuse aujourd'hui le chef du
commando je n'étais pas d'accord dit-il
selon nos instructions le sens ne devait
pas poulet ahmad ezz jugé en allemagne
pour détention d'explosifs et ce malgré
les pressions venues du liban des
menaces sur la vie du dernier otage
allemand rudolf cordesse les aveux
d'aujourd'hui vont sans doute relancer
les demandes d'extradition en provenance
des états unis les tribunaux américains
ont toujours souhaité poser quelques
questions embarrassantes
à mohamed hamadeh du pétrole en plein
paris ou presque aujourd'hui porte
d'ivry tout près du périphérique entre
paris et ivry sur seine un premier
forage pétrolier est entrée en action
cela paraît extravagant et on imagine
bien que le gisement qu'on va explorer
ne sera pas comparable avec ceux du
moyen-orient
mais en matière de pétrole chaque goutte
compte et il faut savoir que 3% de la
consommation française vient déjà du
territoire français patrick esther cela
gicler ce matin sur la plate forme de
forage d'elf total ibilité installé sur
un terrain industriel à 300 mètres
seulement du périphérique
mais pas de précipitation il ne s'agit
pas pour l'instant de pétrole mais
debout remontant à la surface les roches
broyées par le trépan un trépan qui va
fort et 150 m par jour dans trois
semaines
le puits est un drap 2000 mètres
originalité percée à l'horizontale il va
dévier de 1000 mètres latéralement va
passer sous la scène et atteindre une
zone en dessous d'immeubles d'habitation
où l'on espère trouver le pétrole on en
est pas encore certain des présomptions
sont excellentes notes prennent aux
techniciens la preuve reste à faire et
nous vivons maintenant la minute de
vérité de la l'exploration pétrolière
dans cette zone
quand le pétrole va être monté ce qu'on
risque pas de voir les immeubles au
dessus décembre non je ne pense pas le
pétrole et à une profondeur suffisamment
grande pour éviter que les immeubles ne
sert de toute façon la roche qui
contient le pétrole vous savez une roche
poreuse ce n'est pas une grande cavité
où une grotte donc elle reste en place
malgré la pluie de conneries on en
extrait cousy forage un milliard de
centimes
si tout va bien il fournira peut-être
chaque année le dixième de l'essence
nécessaire aux voitures des parisiens
paris texas peut-être maison bien loin
des productions de l'ignoble jr
les ordinateurs de nos enfants ne seront
pas tous français depuis que
l'informatique est enseignée à l'école
les lycées et les collèges c'est qui or
surprise dans sa dernière commande qui
portait sur treize mille ordinateurs
l'état achète du matériel étranger
c'est un suédois victor qui se taille la
part du lion le français groupe il tire
tout de même son épingle du jeu
enquête françoise joly ce sont ces
ordinateurs qui seront installés dès la
rentrée dans les collèges et les lycées
il y en aura d'autres d'autres marques
mais ce sont ceux là qui font grincer
les dents des constructeurs français
parce que ces ordinateurs s'appelle
victor et victor et la filiale de tata
tronic un constructeur suédois
il vient de se tailler la part du lion
dans le dernier marché de
micro-ordinateurs passer par le
ministère de l'éducation nationale
il va fournir près de la moitié des 13
millions commandées en deuxième position
le français s mt goupil qui grognent et
dénonce une concurrence qu'ils jugent
déloyale le point f ce sont des
constructeurs et notamment l'un d'entre
eux qui est très axé sur la filière
taïwanaise façon des gens qui
construisent les chroniques très one et
qui ce faisant bénéficient d'avantagés
fiscaux considérables à l'entrée dans la
cee
mais si victor utilise des composants
asiatique c'est aussi le cas des
constructeurs français
une réaction qui est plutôt révélatrice
d'un autre malaise le plan informatique
pour tous lancé en 1985 avait pour
objectif affiché de promouvoir
l'informatique made in france
mais réalisme oblige le sacro-saint
rapport qualité-prix a fini par ouvrir
le marché aux étrangers l'an passé déjà
rené monory avait choisi du matériel
suédois et américain la fin de la grève
des mineurs de gardanne les mineurs
encore grévistes réunis tout à l'heure
en assemblée générale par la cgt ont
voté à main levée la reprise du travail
celui ci pourrait donc reprendre dès
jeudi après trois mois de conflit sur
les marchés financiers le dollar
s'envole et les financiers s'inquiète le
billet vert a atteint aujourd'hui à
paris six francs 45 une des causes de
cette envolée celle annonce par les
autorités financières américaines du
relèvement du taux d'escompté de 6 à 6
et demi pour cent voyons maintenant le
reste de l'actualité en bref avec rémy
roche
manifestation devant la prison des
baumettes à marseille où sont enfermés
les deux meurtriers présumés de la
petite céline retrouvée morte après
avoir été violée le 27 juillet dernier
parents et amis de la petite victime qui
réclament le rétablissement de la peine
de mort ont fait circuler une pétition
qui a déjà reçu 12 mille signatures
depuis l'annnonce du drame
au moins deux morts et dix blessés à la
suite d'un nouveau raid de l'aviation
israélienne au sud liban le treizième
depuis le début de l'année les avions
israéliens qui ont survolé plusieurs
fois la région de saïda ont bombardé une
base palestinienne détruisant des
installations militaires et une station
de radio 1 million de sans abri au
soudan à la suite de pluies
torrentielles qui viennent de s'abattre
sur le pays
à khartoum la capitale où la situation
semble particulièrement grave on
s'active à rétablir la distribution
d'eau potable et le courant les
autorités qui redoutent le développement
d'épidémies sont pour l'instant
incapable de fournir un bilan des
victimes
nouveaux affrontements en irlande du
nord toute la nuit dernière dans lé
quartier catholique de belfast des
groupes de manifestants ont pas receler
des patrouilles de police qui ont
procédé à une quarantaine d'arrestations
chaque année l'anniversaire de la loi
sur l'alternance on jugement pourtant
aboli en 1975 est l'occasion d'incidents
similaires
la mort du poète félix leclerc le
québécois s'est éteint à 74 ans nous
vous le disions dès hier soir tous ceux
qui aiment la chanson et la poésie ont
été émues à l'annoncé de cette nouvelle
félix leclerc il avait bercé notre
enfance avec ses souliers son petit
bonheur un petit bonheur qui est bien ce
que le poète peut nous apporter de mieux
gérard dalmaz hommage il est mort du
coeur le poème et le coeur il
connaissait printemps de bourges 83
dernier passage chez nous du troubadour
de la francophonie troubadours engagée
puisque ce jour de ma gilles disait non
sans humour que l'onglet garde sa place
dans le monde et que le français
reprennent la sienne c'est à dire la
première comme au temps des rois
quand
diane dufresne que voici gilles
vigneault robert charlebois d'autres
bars de canadiens étaient ses proches
bien sûr mais dès les années 50 félix
leclerc ancien animateur radio débuté
dans le spectacle en même temps que
devos brassens brel ses amis et tous
découvert comme lui par jacques canetti
défricheur de talents
auteur compositeur interprète écrivain
félix leclerc était modeste
je ne suis qu'un racontent eux à 74 ans
il est parti sur la pointe des souliers
mais ce départ fait grand bruit écoutez
robert charlebois aujourd'hui un vison
la romaine
c'était un philosophe c'est quelqu'un
qui dont on ressortait grandi après
chaque contact toute cette conversation
il est au coeur des choses il méprisait
un peu le vedettariat les médias parce
qu'il se voyait comme comme un ouvrier
qui faisait les chansons c'est la
locomotive ya qui a ouvert toutes les
portes croix qui a porté le canada sur
son dos bien avant le québec à travers
toute la francophonie
et surtout il y avait une belle voix on
perd vraiment une très très belle voix
évidemment ils s'étaient tues depuis une
dizaine d'années parce qu'il faisait de
l'emphysème confirme c'est le poumon
directement alors peut-être les grandes
chaleurs de cet été qui ont eu raison de
lui
peut-être qu'ils s'étaient dit je vais
me relever tué de 80 par rapport à tout
ce que je signale quand n 2 rendra
hommage à félix leclerc dimanche à 17h30
notre chaîne rediffusera les meilleurs
moments du grand échiquier que lui avait
consacré jacques chancel et puis je vous
signale aussi la parution de cette
biographie félix leclerc le roi heureux
c'est publié par l'excédent de maisons
d'édition arléa cela dit lorsque félix
leclerc disparaît on prend tout à coup
conscience du rayonnement de notre
langue le français au delà de nos
frontières
c'est tout le problème de la
francophonie une idée parfois abstraites
qui recouvre en fait une réalité
michel mompontet la famille rouleau
presque française mais pourtant sur un
autre continent à 6000 km de paris ou
quand la francophonie devient une idée
vital
eux qui ne s'appelle ni johnny jane mais
justin marguerite
oui c'est important foresterie misère je
serai désespérée si je suis on me disait
qu et petits-enfants le parlement plus
français parce que c'est pas une
question de vocabulaire mais c'est une
question de style de vie qui d'après moi
correspond beaucoup à ce qu on est quand
même être humain ici donc au québec on
parle on mange on respire français mais
comme plus de 150 millions de personnes
dans le monde et ce sur cinq continents
aujourd'hui le français est parlé plus à
l'étranger que dans l'hexagone de
l'europe occidentale à l'asie du sud-est
en passant par l'afrique ou les îles des
caraïbes le français essaient de
rayonner mais cette population
francophone est une véritable mosaïque
de race de couleur
tout le défi de la francophonie et la
communiquer entre eux plus de 60 pays
véhicule de cette communication donc et
enjeux financiers capital de la
francophonie l'audiovisuel bien sûr et
les banques informatique de données en
france est un secteur où l'anglais règne
depuis plus de vingt ans sans partage en
1987 à montréal la première banque
d'information en langue française à
l'étranger et créer support capital à la
télévision européenne
tv5 mais malgré ces innovations
quand il reste un défi de taille à la
francophonie l'existence de deux mondes
d'un côté la francophonie des pays
riches du nord et de l'autre celle des
pauvres du sud
devant de tels éloignement une langue
commune mais parfois qu'un très maigre à
tous et il se trouve que le ministre de
la francophonie c'est quelqu'un qui les
téléspectateurs connaissent très bien
puisque c'est alain decaux alain decaux
merci d'être avec nous ce soir vous êtes
à nice vous ne trouvez pas triste au
fond qu'on ne parle de francophonie
qu'au moment de la mort d'un poète
canadien
d'abord je crois qu'on en parle en bien
d'autres occasions mais voyez vous allez
c'est triste pour tous ceux qui ont aimé
félix leclerc
mais félix leclerc c'est le symbole même
de la francophonie parce que ce
québécois a fait connaître la réalité
québécoise aux français et en même temps
les français ont fait sa gloire
c'est ça la francophonie c'est un
échange vous êtes le ministre d'une idée
alain decaux c'est la francophonie donc
comment est-ce qu'on gère une idée est
ce que vous avez des projets très
concrets lanoux dont pourriez nous
parler mais j'en ai j'en ai tellement
que les très courtes vacances que
m'accorde la république sont passées à
étudier les dossiers je pars je vais
partir dans quelques jours justement
pour le québec parce que on va lancer le
satellite canadien francophone tv5 la
langue française inondant l'amérique du
nord est ce qu'on aurait pu rêver ça il
y a cinq ans ça c'est la francophonie
ensuite il y aura le gabon parce que les
africains s'inquiètent de l'europe
j'irai les rassurer l'europe et la
francophonie ne feront pas mauvais
ménage en suis sûr il y aura la
préparation de dacca le sommet dakar il
y aura aussi les jeux francophones au
maroc le sommet franco africain tout ça
c'est mon calendrier médias alors
beaucoup de projets effectivement est ce
que le fait d'être un homme de médias ça
vous sert beaucoup un symbole de la
société médiatique au fond je voudrais
que ça me sert je voudrais que ça me
serve parce que on me connaît ce qui me
regarde mon bus dans tout cas depuis
longtemps et je voudrais profiter de
cette presque intimité pour expliquer
aux français ce qu'est la francophonie
on ne sait pas assez on ne sait pas
assez que cette communauté solidaire
c'est le nom qu'elle s'est donnée et
bien non seulement et des projets mais
réalise ses projets depuis depuis le
sommet de paris c'est un grand enjeu
pour la france et pour tous les pays qui
se
ensemble mais je crois que ce sera l'un
des grands enjeux de la fin du xxème
siècle et j'essaierai de leur dire
pourquoi au français alain decaux
dernière question là je vais m'adresser
à l'académicien un autre poète est mort
en même temps hier c'est francis ponge
ça ne vous attriste pas au fond qu'on ne
parle des poètes qu'à leur mort j'ai
beaucoup aimé pons a été peut-être la
plus grande émotion de mes 20 ans quand
je les lui alors non ça ne m'attriste
pas parce que un poète ne meurt pas oui
il est parti mais demain je crois que je
relis réponds-je merci monsieur le
ministre
dans l'actualité encore la mort de
robert ricci le couturier il avait 83
ans il avait fondé avec sa mère en 1932
la maison de couture qui était devenu
ensuite nina ricci et puis bien sûr sur
le carnet rose la naissance de la fille
de la duchesse d'york les anglais
attendait cela depuis plusieurs semaines
et l'arrivée d'une nouvelle princesse à
la cour royale d'angleterre et célébrer
comme il se doit
je vous rappelle que la petite princesse
et la fille du prince andrew et de sarah
ferguson
tout le monde se réjouit en angleterre
même le prince édouard qui lui perd une
place dans la hiérarchie de la
succession
claude crespo jusqu'à la deuxième
génération ça va charles sera roi estime
à l'heure ses frères pourraient assurer
la relève à n'intervenant qu'en
quatrième position
pas de problème non plus avec les
enfants de cars et le diana
mais les choses se compliquent avec la
petite princesse sans nom elle vient de
voler à son royal oncle la 5e place dans
la succession au trône dernier enfant de
la reine dont clean est tout à fait
normal que les deux premiers fils passe
avant lui c'est agnel à la cie la
succession se fait de mal en mal et les
filles après
par ordre de primogéniture c'est à dire
que vient d'abord le crachat et ses
enfants ensuite le prince andrew et ses
enfants et le prince édouard et la
princesse anne et ses enfants le sort en
est jeté
peut être un effet pervers de cette
naissance annoncée par ce royal héros
est survenu le huitième jour du huitième
mois de l'an de grâce 88
toujours est il qu edward prince est
célibataire ne se montre pas trop
brusquer sa vocation non pas les marines
sa nature est trop fantaisistes
non ce qu'il aime c'est le théâtre dans
toutes les bonnes familles il y à une
brebis galeuse en anglais black sheep
néanmoins le léger edouard petit-fils
est la quatrième génération de la cda
victoria a préféré endosser le costume
parfois légers des saltimbanques voit la
fin de cette édition du journal le
prochain rendez vous avec l'information
ce sera au brier de l'air un petit peu
après 23 heures tout de suite bien sûr
vous avez rendez vous avec laurent
cabrol pour une météo plus médiocres
enfin nous verrons bien
voilà fin de cette édition excellente
soirée sur antenne 2
oh